and i do this on all of these when i
and i initiate
and in okie though you you always say
who's the attacker not me
and yet if i initiate it makes me this
hacker
but i need to
uh
an american teacher kayla vader who i
was really impressed with she used to
say she was only a young girl when i met
her you say tony shout into the valley
and
listen to the echo and it was uh that's
what gave me the idea if i do that and
keep on here
the strongest person wins
it's called an attorney if i if i do
this
touch and then take off
his brain for a split second doesn't
register that i'm attacking him
so it's it's uh it's an attempt like a
bluff to make him go what and in that
what moment
you tap them down
without that
your up gets this straight and you get
about here and then it starts getting
difficult
just to add that like will splash
they go down
now
this is the tricky bit i step in
if i set them too far you could grab
that leg
so i have to
step in here now there's i've got to
take this this hand off so it's it's a
tricky moment so what i do is i'll
replace it
with this
like that i just go a little bit forward
i don't leave it there and just go like
that unless you can come up
so i replace it and i
do a quarter step forward that means he
has to then get his balance while it
gives me a moment to get his hand load
i now follow the line
up my key
as i stand up and i turn my torso
towards you that puts that applies the
technique
if i don't turn towards him
you stand up here
and he's okay he's going
you've not got me so i
turn my torso towards him like that i
pretend that this but really this is
doing nothing it was like
turning on the torso
i now
make a step
like
and i'll this
this hand on the top part of my leg and
i just press it here
too much information isn't it
i love it
because it is
technical
so most people in the harvey to do this
do this and get this camera
most men will do that so that's why
people often pack up my keto because
they're going i can't take that too much
bullying for me
splash
down
when you make the splashes before you be
more advanced when you make a splash
you've got to turn your hand like that
right splash
but